[Musique]
stages sportifs au soleil pour nos
gramounes de toute l'île l'indicateur ce
sont ces chaises qui se déplace dans les
5 ha du village corail et la motivation
est juste exemplaire pour ces stagiaires
d'un jour parce qu'il faut entretenir le
camp tous les shows me bouffe je pendrai
bay près de la mer
des consignes adaptées par des
spécialistes du sport santé souplesse
agilité mémoire et équilibre permettent
de lutter contre la paire d'auteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
à
normal non normalement pour le challenge
il aussi sa vraie cible de tirs à la
combe hors du terrain le regard enjoué
orfi observe sa maman de 82 ans en
action par la droite différemment
l'avait jamais fait de sport au bond
jamais elle manche et a fait avec tapas
parce qu'il était cardiaque il fallait
qu'ils marchent pour maintenir mais
s'ils n'ont jamais fait de sport et donc
quand elle a commencé c'est vrai que
c'est là la voix évolue autrement et du
coup elle a en fait chez elle elle
ramène des exercices chez elle à nous
explique comment il faut faire c'est
bien ça permet de créer un lien aussi
avec les petits enfants et tout ça c'est
bien dans les 24 communes de l'île et
toutes les semaines cette association
accompagné par le département s'occupe
de mille deux cents licenciés
nous ce que nous voulons c'est arrivé à
ce que les seniors quitte le domicile
familial ça ils le font avec les avocats
ccs d'ailleurs je remercie au passage
l'ensemble d'essayer de la réunion à
laquelle nous travaillons en étroite
collaboration
mais surtout nous faisons des actions
comme on fait aujourd'hui jeu des
regroupements tous les deux mois ça
permet aux gens de quitter leur quartier
de quitter la petite résidence et de
retrouver d'autres personnes dans
d'autres villes
ce cadre d'expression à vocation sociale
est un des objectifs affirmés du
département le loisir fait partie aussi
du bien-être et de la cohésion que nous
retrouverons dans notre population qui
aujourd'hui a encore des difficultés peu
de moyens pour pouvoir profiter des
vacances comme n'importe qui d'autre est
bien le village corail aujourd'hui
présente cette situation comme étant
favorable à l'accès aussi bien pour les
jeunes les seniors et les personnes
épidémique
cette action illustre le développement
d'une silver economy à la veille du
doublement de la population des
personnes âgées
et c'est dans la piscine que cette
journée se termine comme elle a commencé
dans la bonne
[Musique]
à